the holiday season is in full swing and
joining us to share how to stay in the
spirit with some spirits is entertaining
expert paul zahn who is sponsoring this
segment
hey paul it's always great to have you
on the show and i'm excited because
today we're talking about one of my
favorites holiday drinks how you doing
buddy
tis the season for holiday cocktails i'm
in good spirit i know you have uh three
drinks or three uh specialties you're
gonna talk about today what do you have
for us
well first up we have some stro 160
spiced rum so this is an iconic spiced
rum from austria it is perfect in a wide
variety of holiday drinks from hot
drinks like hot cocoa to you can even
just put some ginger beer in this and it
is the spirit of austria it's perfect
for baking and the reason why it has 160
in the name is because it's 160 proof
which means you can make some tiki
cocktails you can set them on fire be
safe people don't burn down the house
with the straw but strow 160 is great
and you can pick this up at total wine
you said something there though you said
it's great for baking so i can put this
in if i'm making some cookies or some
kind of i don't know christmas cake i
can add the uh the liquor into my baked
goods
absolutely it's got some nice vanilla
some caramel so it's perfect for all
holiday treats what's the next item you
have for us
next up we have some larson cognac aqua
igni so in latin aqua means water and
ignees means fire and this is a special
cognac because it's made with a steam
fire process so each french oak barrel
is plunged into hot water and then
toasted over fire three times so what
that's gonna do it's gonna yield some
really great notes of vanilla it's got
some nice spice raisin to it it even has
some mocha to it so again this makes
some great cocktails you put this in
your hot cocoa but i love just sipping
this meat by the fire pit and just you
know if you like cigars you can light up
a cigar but the larsen cognac aguero in
aqua nice is perfect especially if
you're going to someone's house and you
can get this at lease discount liquor
because you know you need to bring a
host gift and all these are great for
host gifts if you're going to aspara
what do you think that's a great idea
too yeah gift giving these are great for
consumption for ourselves but also for
gift giving to friends and loved ones
and that's something too like you said
there i envision having that drink by a
fire maybe you're outside you go up to
the mountains you're doing some skiing
and playing out in the snow that's a
nice little drink that'll warm you up
absolutely and my last but certainly not
least one and i like your thought one
for you one for me we love that i have
some mozart chocolate liqueur so what
this is this is made in austria much
like oats are a mozart came from austria
and this is made with some delicious
belgian chocolate and they really have a
wide variety of items they have their
dark chocolate which this one is vegan
they have pumpkin spice i'm a pumpkin
spice fan we have some chocolate cream
and then we also have the mozart
chocolate coffee which i've made a fun
little spiked iced coffee right here and
again this is a great addition to any
sort of cocktail you can pour this over
ice cream and you can order this at
reservebar.com and the only thing
missing is some
whipped cream on my this is like a
frappuccino now so you can pick up the
mozart reserve bar.com and i think this
is covered for holiday cocktails right
you really do this is great you can be
sitting around christmas morning opening
up your gifts i'm just drinking coffee
you guys it's just coffee i swear
see we're gonna get along swimmingly
this is fantastic paul thank you so much
and happy holidays to you my friend
cheers